[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
jeudi 2 novembre voici le programme de
ce soir le vent a bien soufflé
aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines la tempête
kirane a frappé le département avec des
pointes à 100 km/h les ventsforts ont
engendré de nombreuses perturbations
dans les transports en commun mais les
pompiers ne communiquent pas de grands
dégâts matériels la situation devrait se
calmer cette nuit météo France annonce
un retour à la normale demain c'est le
grand chantier dans les Yvelines le
nouveau métro du Grand Paris Express
poursuit son développement les travaux
de la gare de Saint-Quentin est ont
démarré cette nouvelle ligne reliera
l'aéroport d'Orly à versaill chantier
d'ici 2030 on fait le point dans cette
émission le jeudi comme d'habitude nous
vous donnerons nos idées de sortie dans
les evelines au programme de ce soir un
bal country à plaisir des histoires qui
font peur ou encore une exposition sur
la Première Guerre mondiale nous vous
emmènerons également en balade l'office
du tourisme de Saint-Germain enly
propose plusieurs parcours tout du long
de la scène du blues de la SA et du jazz
le festival Blues sur scène revient dans
le nord des evvelines pour une 24e
édition nous en parlerons avec notre
invité du 78 et all est en PL avec nous
bonsoir Chantal chipelletti bonsoir
alors vous êtes la présidente du
festival Blues sur scène blouses sur
scène c'est un festival itinérant qui
passe dans 10 communes yvelinoises avec
au total une douzaine de concerts on en
parlera un peu plus en détail en fin
d'émission avec nous également sur ce
plateau une journaliste de la rédaction
de tv78 Gabrielle Gontier bonsoir
bonsoir math vous allez nous présenter
comme d'habitude le jeudi vos idées de
sortie dans les zivelines mais avant on
va faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les zivelines
[Musique]
et on commence ses informations Gabriel
par la tempête Kiran qui a continué de
toucher les ivelines aujourd'hui oui
Mathilde la vigilance orange vent a été
levée ce matin dans les ivelines mais
les rafales ont persisté jusqu'en début
d'après-midi entre 75 et 90 kmh selon
Météo France elle devrait se poursuivre
jusqu'en fin de journée généralement
inférieur à 85 kmh et plus localisé par
mesure de prè prévention un arrêté
préfectoral a interdit l'accès au bois
et forêt du département toute la journée
certains parcs et jardins étaient
également interdit d'accès côté
transport le trafic a été complètement
interrompu dans certaines gares une
situation qui a contraint de nombreux
voyageurs à s'adapter du coup on est
forcé à prendre des uber ou des taxis
sauf que bah tout le monde se rabat sur
ça donc on est encore encore dans
l'attente ça fait depuis maintenant euh
je dirais 9h un peu moins même 8h30 9h
que j'attends et voilà après je sais
même pas s'il y a les bus aussi euh j'ai
entendu dire que c'était bondé donc je
m'y risque pas et moi je dois aller
vraiment sur Paris donc c'est pour le
travail c'est ça exactement c'est pour
le travail je suis étudiant en
alternance du
coup je suis un peu dans la dans le
stress alors la circulation devrait
rapidement revenir à la normale en
revanche consulter les réseaux sociaux
des modes de transport que vous
empruntez et finalement est-ce que la
tempête kyrienne a fait des dégâts dans
les ivelines alors d'après le service
départemental d'un et de secours des
Yvelines il y a pas eu de dégâts majeurs
à noté majoritairement des chutes
d'arbres rapidement pris en charge à PO
si ce sont des plaques métalliques d'un
immeuble de Neu étages qui se sont
envolé heureusement aucun blessé n'est à
déploré la gendarmerie a quanttinelle
recensé près de 200 appels à 7h ce matin
contre une trentaine d'habitudes
beaucoup d'interventions ont eu lieu
pour des chaussées obstrues on poursuit
ses information Gabriel par un nouveau
commissariat qui doit voir le jour à H
encours oui situé au Parc des Sports qui
Boniface les travaux du nouveau
commissariat viennent de commencer il
coordonnera notamment les effectifs de
trois commissariats de Saint-Quentin en
yeline des innovations technologiques
qui seront déployées les policiers
auront accès à des drones pour les
situations de crise un stand de tir
virtuel ou encore un simulateur de
conduite sous tension 18 mois de travaux
sont sont à prévoir ouverture prévue
Mathilde courant 2025 un peu de football
à présent on sait qui va affronter
ouille pour la 7e tour de la Coupe de
France il s'agit du dernier club des
yvelin encore en liste dans la
compétition oui le tirage au sort du 7e
tour de la Coupe de France a eu lieu ce
mardi 1er novembre à Claire Fontaine les
hommes de Michel Siani recevront anger
un club de Ligue 2 un gros tirage pour
ouille puisque le club évolue quatre
divisions en dessous en Régionale 1 les
matchs se dérouleront le weekend du 18
et du 19 novembre on termine ces
informations Gabriel par un point trafic
puisqu'il va falloir s'armer de patience
ce weekend oui pour ce dernier weekend
de vacances de la toussin les vacanciers
seront nombreux dans le sens des retours
des difficultés de circulation sont
attendues vendredi et samedi
principalement sur les axe convergant
vers l'Île-de-France il est conseillé de
vous déplacer avant 14h selon les
dernières prévisions dimanche 5 novembre
tous les voyants sont auverts pour le
moment et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
news une ligne de métro pouvant relier
l'aéroport d'Orly à Versailles chantier
c'est le projet de la ligne 18 ce
nouveau métro du Grand Paris Express
poursuit son développement les travaux
de la gare 51 est ont d'ailleurs démarré
la nouvelle station située à guillancour
devrait sortir de terre en 2030 et
accueillir chaque jour 30000 voyageurs
c'est le reportage de Julien
Leroi
un balai d'engin pour un chantier
d'envergure depuis février 2023 les
travaux de la future gar Saint-Quentin
est ont débuté à guillencour une
cinquantaine d'ouvriers travaillent sur
cette construction ce site fait partie
des 10 stations de métro bientôt
desservi par la ligne 18 du Grand Paris
Express 35 km de voie entre l'aéroport
dorly et Versailles-Chantier on prévoit
30000 voyageurs par jour dans cette gare
euh la gare de Saint-Quentin c'est ça va
être euh une ouverture vers vers les les
pôles économiques et de recherche de du
plateau de saclai et aussi vers les
pôles d'échange et d'intermodalité ici
on est sur les travaux de terrassement
de du la future bois de gare plus de 150
p ont été plantés pour maintenir la
structure bétonnée un niveau de terre
progressivement abaissé jusqu'à bientôt
atteindre la hauteur des futures rames à
15 m sous le sol dès l'été 2024 un
tunnelier entrera en piste pour ner le
tronçon vers larê verers chantier une
fois que le creusement du tunnel est
terminé à l'horizon 2027 on peut
envisager l'installation de de de
l'entreprise qui va réaliser l'émergence
principale et l'émergenence secondaires
de la gare on pourrait retrouver des
commerces de proximité des kiosques de
l'achat de ticket un site implanté à
proximité immédiate du Technocentre
Renault et ses 10000 salariés en
parallèle se développera autour de la
future gare le quartier des savoirs 2
logement et 3000 m car de boutique une
forte zone d'activité pour cette station
où sera prévu un train toutes les 90
secondes en heure de pointe ce sont des
lignes qui sont
automatiques qui ont des postes de
commandement centralisés dans leur
centre d'exploitation ou déportés dans
des gare ici le poste de commandement
centralisé il est situé à palzo la mise
en service d'un premier tronçon entre la
ville de Massie et le plateau de sacelet
est prévu dès 2026 pour la gare 51 est
il faudra patienter jusqu'à 2030 avec
l'ouverture complète de la ligne
18 c'est l'heure à présente de votre
rubrique sur le bien-être animal ce soir
on s'intéresse à l'adoption mais surtout
à l'adoption responsable un engagement
important pour la Société protectrice
des animaux l'adoption responsable
permet d'éviter les risques d'abandon au
refuge de la SPA de plaisir Jessie
willin de nos confrères de radio
sensation a suivi une famille qui
souhaite adopter un
chien
chaque année la Société protectrice des
animaux organise des journées portes
ouvertes aujourd'hui on va suivre romain
Nathalie et Benoît ils viennent
rencontrer une nouvelle fois Pablo ça
fait la deuxième fois que vous venez
rencontrer Pablo aujourd'hui pourquoi
cette cette deuxième rencontre sur la
fiche de description du site là il
correspondait en tout point à ce qu'on
recherchait comme comme animal puis
c'est un projet aussi avec mon éfous
qu'on avait depuis très longtemps pour
adopter un animal plutôt de la SPA pour
donner une seconde chance un anim qui a
pas forcément une vie facile onè fois
avec Romain un de nos enfants pour voir
comment ça va se passer avec lui cette
deième
rcontre Pablo est en train de de
rencontrer sa potentielle famille ses
potentiels adoptants pourquoi les faire
rencontrer dans dans un parc alors on
les fait rencontrer dans un parc pour
commencer pour être sûr que le chien
accepte les personnes et aussi que les
personnes voilà se rend compte de la
taille du chien de la puissance du chien
des petites choses qui auraient à
travailler l'animal reste votre priorité
de toute façon dans les adoptions tout à
fait c'est notre priorité et c'est aussi
le confort de la famille on va pas
placer un chien où les gens sont pas à
l'aise où l'animal est pas à l'aise non
plus parce que ça il y a des grandes
chances que ça se passe pas très bien
chez eux et qu'il reviennent au final
c'est un échec pour tout le monde pour
nous pour le chien et pour la famille il
va avoir besoin de ces momentsl de jeu
en fait ça donc il faut trouver des
endroits de
verdure pour pouvoir le faire jouer
alors quitte à mettre une grande longe
si on veut pas le détacher mais il faut
qu'il puisse à un moment donné décharger
après les présentations Pablo part en
balade avec Romain Nathalie et Benoît
l'objectif est simple savoir si Pablo
peut s'adapter à sa nouvelle famille
c'est
bien romain on vous a quitté tout à
l'heure avec Pablo finalement là vous
êtes avec une une autre chienne est-ce
que c'est finalement elle que que vous
allez choisir et pourquoi bah a priori
oui en fait on avait eu quelques
quelques problèmes avec Pablo parce que
bon c'est un grand chien il est gentil
il est calme mais il a l'air quand même
puissant on s'est dit bon voilà c'est
pe-être on va peêtre partir sur un chien
d' plus petit calibre donc là en fait
c'est à peu près le même c'est le même
croisement mais en version plus petite
et surtout elle est très très calme très
gentil tire pas du tout sur la la pour
repartir avec pocket Nathalie et Benoît
doivent signer et fournir quelques
documents et payer les frais d'adoption
ce soir pocket aura une nouvelle famille
on va partir avec pocket en espérant que
elle s'adapte à la maison et à notre
présence mais aussi à nos absences et
cetera un grand plaisir franchement un
grand
plaisir vous étiez venu finalement pour
pour Pablo vous repartez avec pocket
est-ce que encore une fois le dicton
c'est le chien qui choisit son maître et
est encore valable euh ouais on peut
dire ça ouais ouais les deux les deux il
faut qu'il a une rencontre c'est une
rencontre avec un animal he c'est du
vivant donc il y a le courant passe plus
ou moins bien et puis puis faut prendre
le caractère des chiens avec le nôutre
au refuge de plaisir ce sont 84 chiens
150 chats et quelques NAC nouveaux
animaux de compagnie qui attendent
encore d'être
adoptés alors n'hésitez pas à sauter le
pas si vous aussi vous voulez avoir un
animal de compagnie pensez à l'adoption
c'est l'heure à présent de passer à
notre page
[Musique]
loisir et on ouvre cette page loisir
avec une balade en bord de scène monie
Renoir de gaz cicelé ces peintres
impressionnistes ont tous vécu ou
séjournés dans les Yvelines et pour
connaître un peu plus leur histoire et
leurs tableau qu'ils ont peint sur le
territoire yvelinois la région île-de-
France a financé la création de SEP
nouveau parc par courours de randonnée
Louis Douchin et Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude ont exploré un de ses parcours
regardez c'est un musée en plein air
cette ville de Saint-Germain boucle de
scène vous invite à suivre leurs
nouveaux chemins impressionnistes de
petite randonnée de 2 à 5 km balisé de
reproduction d'œuvres placé là où les
artistes ont posé leur chevalet en fait
il y a plus de 200 œuvres qui ont été
peintes à Saint-Germain boucle de scèes
que ce soit Saint-Germain en laè Chatou
croissie le port marli et et j'en oublie
euh donc on n' pas pu toutes les avoir
il fallait d'abord qu'il y ait une bonne
définition il fallait qu'il y ait une
cohérence on voulait que ça ça crée un
parcours intéressant avec des sujets
aussi euh différents certains vont vont
évoquer les loisirs d'autres vont
évoquer l'industrialisation enfin les
sujets sont différents et on voulait
justement sensibiliser à l'époque c'est
vraiment un moyen de découvrir l'époque
de fin 19e début début 20e en longeant
la scène le parcours du por Marle est le
plus petit mais le plus dense avec 12
tableaux une ville qu'afred cisley
affectionne il a peint de nombreuses
toiles sur cette commune comme en 1876
où la crue de la scène lui offre un
sujet de travail sur un motif qu'il
chérit tant l'eau et ses reflets ce sont
pas les premiers à être sensibles à la
beauté des lieux je pense tout d'abord à
des rois ce qui était le privilège un
privilège royal euh l'apanage des des
des grandes semondes va se démocratiser
au 19e siècle et ce sont nos peintres et
bien qui vont vouloir immortaliser ces
paysages véritable terre de
l'impressionnisme de l'ancienne forge du
centre-ville jusqu'à l'abevoir de marli
Leroi sur chaque parcours différents
sujets sont abordés certains vont
évoquer les loisirs de la société de
l'époque alors que d'autres vont montrer
l'industrialisation des lieux un témoin
de l'histoire de la fin du 19e début 20e
siècle donc à Saint-Germain boucle de
scè l'idée c'est effectivement que que
les habitants découvrent pour ceux qui
connaissent pas bah tous les tableaux
qui ont été été peint ici par une
quinzaine d'artistes et c'est aussi de
les inciter à se balader tout simplement
pour compléter la visite l'Office de
Tourisme propose pour chaque œuv des
activités à faire dans les environs à
l'heure actuelle C parcours sont
disponibles de randonnées
supplémentairire ouvriront au printemps
2024 à Louvre sienne et Saint-Germain en
lait et dans cette même optique le
département des iveline a lui aussi créé
un circuit de randonnée sur les peintres
impressionnistes il s'est associé au
Comité des départemental de randonnée
pédestre pour créer un itinéraire de 128
km partant de la Maison Fournaise à
Chatou jusqu'au musée Mony à Giverny il
traverse 32 communes et se compose de H
étapes qui sont toutes accessibles en
train alors si vous voulez tester ce
nouveau g n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur le site internet
rando-eveline.fr on poursuit cette page
loisir avec vos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines Gabriel qu'est-ce que vous nous
proposez ce soir bon vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir Mathilde que halloween c'est
fini mais pourquoi pas prolonger la fête
samedi l'association villeeverte propose
aux plus téméraires de venir venir
écouter des histoires terrifiantes tout
ça au cœur de la forêt départementale de
la Madeleine une façon de découvrir la
Vallée de Chevreuse d'une manière
originale et faire vivre encore un peu
Hoï et alors après ces histoires
effrayantes Gabriel vous nous plongez
dans une ambiance un peu plus américaine
oui l'association plaisir plaisiroise
cowboy at dancer propose son
traditionnel et concert country au
programme démonstration et initiation à
la danse country mais aussi concert
proposé par le groupe country rock
rocking chairs si ça vous intéresse
Mathilde il ne vous reste plus qu'à
revêtir votre chapeau et vos santiagu je
vais peut-être devoir aussi réviser
quelques pas de Dan on poursuit vos
idées de sortie Gabriel avec une
traditionnelle course ivelinoise oui la
course royale de Fontenet le fleurir
revient s lancant de la pièce d'eau des
Suisses pour rejoindre FONTENAY LE
Fleury coureur expérimenté ou famille en
quête de nouvelles expériences il y a
forcément une course pour vous cette
année proposé un semi-marathon un 10,m5
mais aussi une course familial des
dossards seront à gagner durant la
course pour participer au 10 km du
marathon pour tous de Paris 2024 et on
termine Gabriel avec deux expositions la
première se trouve à Versailles oui
nourrir le soldat au front c'est
l'intitulé de l'exposition que propose
la ville de Versailles constitué de
textes de photos de cartes postales issu
d'archives l'exposition retrace l'IST de
l'alimentation des soldats alliés et du
soldat allemand durant la Première
Guerre mondiale une immersion dans une
facette méconnue de l'histoire mais
riche d'informations sur la vie des
soldats au front et la deuxième
exposition que vous nous proposez
Gabriel elle se trouve à Clairefontaine
oui le Centre d'art La Chapelle rend
hommage à Bruno Barbet en mettant à
l'honneur les photographies du photo
journaliste l'exposition s'intitule
palette méditerranéenne du Portugal au
Maroc à travers son objectif Bruno
Barbet a passé sa carrière à
photographier la diversité culturelle et
l'authenticité du pourtour méditerranéen
donnant naissance à des clichés colorés
et nuancés l'exposition m'-il d' à
découvrir jusqu'au 25 février et bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces idées de sortie c'est bientôt
l'heure de l'invité du 78 mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions rester
au sec normalement météo France prévoit
quelques nuages avec des éclair clci au
niveau des températures ça se refroidit
il fera 6°gr à rambouiller 7 à Oudan et
Versailles et 8 à Montel jolie demain
après-midi mêmes condition météo
quelques nuages et du soleil côté
température compté 10° à rambouillé 11 à
Versailles et 12 à Oudan et Montel jolie
et le vent continuera de souffler dans
les ivelines il sera tout de même moins
fort attendez-vous à des rafales entre
40 et 50 kmh et demain nous fêterons la
saint uber c'est l'heure maintenant de
passer à l'invité du 78
[Musique]
le festival Blues sur scène est de
retour dans le nord des Yvelines pour sa
24e édition cette année il s'étale du
vendredi 10 novembre au jeudi 26
novembre comme d'habitude le festival
reste itinérant il va se déplacer dans
une dizaine de communes pour en parler
avec nous Chantal cipeletti la
présidente du festival alors Chantal pti
c'est la 24e édition selon vous
qu'est-ce qui fait le succès de ce
festival vous savez une des une des des
des des choses importantes de ce
festival c'est qu'il est itinérant nous
ne restons pas sur le même site tous les
jours nous changeons de scène nous
changeons de salle nous changeons de
ville et nous essayons d'amener le
spectacle vivant au plus près des
spectateurs c'est ce qui fait que les
spectateurs reviennent d'année en année
aussi voà ils ont l'habitude ils savent
et alors comme son nom l'un on a du
blues du jazz de la sou de la sol ou
quels sont les les tous les types de
musique différents qui son prés
commencer par par un gospel cette année
puisqu'on reçoit le Golden Gate qui est
quand même un groupe tout à fait
mythique qui arrive des États-Unis et
qui viendra je
pense à la collégiale deande qui est
quand même un lieu magnifique c'est la
tête d'affiche de ce festival tête
d'affiche de cette 24e édition il y aura
également ce soir-là une chorale locale
qui viendra pour partager la scène en
fin de concert chaque année vous vous
renouvelez dans la programmation le but
c'est que ça touche un public le plus
large possible le plus large possible on
essaie de de pour les nostalgiques de de
par exemple comme cette année on a prévu
une soirée hommage à Jimmy Hendrix mais
une soirée uniquement féminine qui est
portée par Nina hatal il n'y aura que
des dames sur scène on essaie aussi de
de d'amener le blues d'aujourd'hui parce
que il est quand même très vivant avec
le groupe d'aval par exemple donc on
essaie de de faire en sorte que chacun
il trouve quelque chose il trouve son
bonheur alors on va revenir sur la tête
d'affiche Golden Gate Quartet ils vont
ouvrir le festival le vendredi 10
novembre vous l'avez dit à la collégiale
de Mantel jolie pourquoi est-ce que il
faut aller les voir pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faut absolument aller les voir il
faut aller les voir parce que parce que
c'est c'est vraiment vous savez ils ont
ils ont près de 70 ans de existance
c'est vraiment le ENF c'est un groupe
mythique toutes les générations peuvent
se retrouver dans ce dans ce groupe qui
est quand même assez extraordinaire je
vous invite à aller sur le site du
festival et vous aurez des extraits si
jamais conna parle d'extraits je vous
propose qu'on en écoute un et on
continue d'en parler juste
après
[Musique]
il reste des places pour aller les voir
chant il reste des places encore
quelques places pour pour le concert du
de la collégia ou et pour les autres
dates aussi encore oui vous savez on est
encore à 15 jours hein donc oui oui il
reste encore des places donc il y a le
temps tout à l'heure on disait une
dizaine de communes vous allez vous
déplacer dans une dizaine de communes
quelles sont les villes alors je vais
peut-être pas vous citer parce que je
vais pas en oublier mais on on va
comment ça s'appelle à Conflant
saintonorine à Limet à Mantel jolie et
des petits villages également du Vexin
c'est important de mêler les deux ah oui
oui oui oui oui les ivelines sont sont
un département avec des grandes villes
mais aussi très rurales donc il faut
effectivement aller dans les villages
des concerts sont aussi organisés à
l'emmaus de folinville d'anemont et au
Foyer des Jeunes Travailleurs de Mantel
jolie pourquoi est-ce que vous avez fait
ce choix-là ces choix-là parce que ce
sont des publics dans ces établissements
qui n'iront peut-être pas acheter un
billet pour aller voir un concert donc
c'est extrêmement important de l'amener
sur place
emus c'est un concert que l'on
on y va tous les ans chez Maus et
franchement on a un accueil assez
extraordinaire et on est très heureux
d'y être et je pense que les compagnons
sont très heureux de nous recevoir aussi
et quel sera l'artiste qui va se
produire devant le foyer sera Justine
blue Justine blue et alors parmi les
communes habituées au festivalù on a
fontené Saint-Père ça faisait 12 ans que
il y avait des concerts dans l'église de
la commune cette année le curé a refusé
pourquoi je pense qu'il faudrait lui
demander à lui en premier vous AZ pas
donné de raison il nous a simplement dit
qu'il ne souhaitait pas cette musique
dans son église il le prêtre d'une
église et et seul maître à bord hein de
son église donc aucun nous sommes pliés
à ces exigences ceci dit on ira on ira
discuter et puis on verra si on peut
quand même pas continuer un petit peu
notre collaboration qui est quand même
importante pour les gens de font les un
père vous avez fait comment pour vous
réorganiser parce qu'il y avait des
enfants qui devaient les enfants qui
devaient donc restituer le travail
puisque à blous sur scè nous avons un
intervenant blouses ils ont six séances
dans leur classe depuis le mois de
septembre et il restitu devant leurs
parents et le
public donc pendant le festival donc
cette année ben pour Fontenet Saint-Père
malheureusement il n aura pas de concert
et les enfants vont restituer dans la
salle dans une des salles municipales et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu aussi l'ADN de
de ce festival les enfants qui
restituent V ça fait très longtemps que
blous sur scène va dans les lycées va
dans les collèges va dans les écoles
primaires je nous trouvons ça vraiment
très très important que les d'amener le
spectacle vivant là où sont les les gens
qui peuvent l'écouter et puis le
lendemain de leur concert les artistes
vont aussi aller voir les enfantsû vous
avez par exemple le New blue generation
qui qui arrive tous les ans et le
lendemain ils vont lycéere le matin et
collège l'après-midi alors pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez d'intégré de ces
enfants au festival vous le disiez
c'était c'était important pour vous
c'est c'est important pour nous le blues
c'est c'est c'est une niche quand même
les enfants ne connaissent pas tous
l'histoire du Blue parce que quand on
intervient dans les écoles on raconte
aussi l'histoire du blues on ne fait pas
il y a de la musique bien sûr mais en
même temps qu'on apprend la musique on
apprend aussi ce qui était le le le pays
dans lequel est né ce ce cette musique
c'est et c'est très important ce qui
fait la force de ce festival aussi c'est
de mêler des des artistes français des
des artistes internationaux des grands
artistes mais aussi des plus petits
artistes émergant bien sûr la scène
locale c'est c'est extrêmement important
qu'il y ait qu'il y ait ce mélange parce
que chacun se côtoie peut enfin c'est
oui oui c'est c'est très important on a
beaucoup de groupes de la scène locale
également sur tracture blues on prend
aussi beaucoup de de groupes de de la
scène locale quels seront les les
artistes locaux alors pour cette 24e
édition ça va être difficile de vous les
dire comme ça il y aura il y aura la
fonction il y aura Lucy il y aura qui
sont des des des groupes locaux vous les
retrouverez à man-elaville pour le la
fin du du festival et bien merci
beaucoup Chantal sipellti d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et d'être venu
en plateau jusqu'à nous je vous souhaite
un un bon 24e festival si vous êtes
intéressé le festival blouses sur scène
c'est du vendredi 10 novembre au au
jeudi 26 novembre une douzaine de
concerts sont prévus n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écan d'écran
pardon pour plus de renseignement et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur tv78 et un bon weekend
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous